all right Jennifer Yes Jennifer where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally
um I grew up uh in the city of Alhambra
um it's in San Gabriel Valley
and tell me about your family you had
Mom and Dad
um yes I have My adoptive mom
um she's the one that primarily raised
me because
um I got taken away from my parents
um at Birth due to them using
methamphetamines
um they didn't try any means to try to
get custody back of me they kind of just
gave up
um all my siblings are were all of we're
all put in foster care so we're all
separated
how would you describe your childhood
um
I had a really rough childhood because I
was confused
um you know in my with my adopted family
I was always a black sheep because since
they were not my blood family like I
always felt indifferent and
um so I started going through depression
at a really young age
um and as well as having ADHD I couldn't
focus in school
um so it was really hard for me to get
good grades in school I was always
failing I would eventually start
ditching School
and um eventually I started going on
MySpace and meeting older men and
um like at a very young age actually at
the age of 14 so that's when I started
to like kind of like Wonder like oh
what's sex about you know like because
you know I was I was attracted to men
and stuff at the time was there any
sexual abuse in your childhood oh yes I
actually met a guy off Myspace
um at a park in La and he uh he raped me
um he was 19 I was 14 and you know I
told him no he kept going and and that's
how I lost my virginity so at that time
I felt like I felt like a
I felt like a disgrace you know because
like I felt disgusting I felt really
disgusted with myself because I felt
like I could have done something about
it and I didn't you know uh I was
molested at the age of four four years
old at a preschool by one of the uh by
one of the teacher aides
um so like I started thinking about sex
at a really young age because I was I
you know I was abused
um
as a child and then
as a teenager so you know my mom never
really spoke to me about my mom that
adopted me never spoke to me about uh
sex she didn't even like to talk to me
about periods because
um she didn't want me to grow up too
quick
um you know and it's ironic because you
know little does she know that I I was
molested and raped you know at a young
age
what can I give you in high school
I was rebellious
um
I was a pothead
um I you never saw me in school and if
you saw me in school I would be like
this on the desk I wouldn't you know I
didn't like to look at the teacher I
didn't like to look at the board I don't
like to do homework schoolwork nothing I
don't like to socialize I just hated
school
I hated it and it got to the point to
where I like would just go off with men
or older guys and stay with them in
their houses and just get loaded get
high and and just put off school was
that your ADHD that kind of not not so
much that I think I think it was so much
of the uh that and the sexual abuse yeah
the the things that the people that hurt
me and the things that I went through at
such young age that was on my mind too
much I was focusing too much on it and
the fact that I felt like I couldn't
communicate with my family that adopted
me the way that I wish I could it was a
big block it was a big blocker for me I
feel like I couldn't like connect with
them on a personal level because they
would always judge me all the time too
day-to-day couldn't understand me they
couldn't figure me out because like they
never dealt with a drug addicted child
you know because I was born addicted to
drugs you know
um so
yeah um your adopted family was was good
there were good uh protective you know
um
they're not bad people you know um
little do they know that I I had to deal
with abuse outside of the home you know
um I've had abusive relationships
um I've never fit in to begin with
anywhere people never really could
relate to me or understand I mean I
thought I was weird you know because I
was very I've always been very quiet a
very quiet person not outgoing and to
them that that that's weird you know
they couldn't understand why it couldn't
be normal
you know
so
a drug use started for you when at uh
16.
sorry on 16. I started smoking weed
smoking spice and drinking alcohol
and that wasn't doing nothing for me it
got to that point so I was like okay let
me try math
you know so I tried math and then that
stopped working for me so I started
slamming meth and then that sort of
stopped working so I'm like let me try
some heroin you know let me try it let
me try the opposite and that worked I
worked along with using smoking pills
and m30 pills
um and then fentanyl came out and then
that's when everything changed for me
you know like it made me it made me feel
like
I didn't give a [ __ ] about anything you
know
I didn't care what people thought about
me you know I I didn't care about the
way that they look at me like it just
I'm gonna be me you know and that's when
I cut my hair I you know dress I dress
like a guy sometimes if I feel like it
and I don't care if somebody's gonna
look at me and think that I look weird
you know or because people do question
me that a lot every day they'll ask me
are you a guy or a girl and it it does
frustrate me and aggravates me because
it's only common sense that I'm a female
like it's like it's ignorant to me you
know and and I don't understand how
somebody could be so ignorant you know
and try to waste my time by asking such
a an obvious question you know
um I have to deal with a lot of hatred
outside
being homeless like a lot of hatred you
know it's not easy getting up every
morning if I do get some sleep waking up
in an alley near
a garbage pit or something you know with
the garbage man trying to pick up trash
yelling at you or Waking Up in a parking
lot in security like hassling you and
just and giving you literally not even
five minutes to get your stuff together
you know and and throwing your [ __ ]
around and just being very rude and
disrespectful it's not easy every day
what's the hardest part of this
lifestyle for you
um there's a woman it's tough keeping
myself safe
because a lot of men do approach me and
a lot of men
are disrespectful and a lot of them are
liars and I have to deal with that I
have to manipulate them every day you
know
to just to save my own ass
just to get me out of situations so I
don't get hurt
you know
if you had bad things happen yes I've
been raped before out here you know
across the street from Union Station
I've been raped and it's it's not easy
for me to just open the open up and say
that to somebody but I think it'd be
good for people to know them so that
they're aware of the dangers of what
could happen to never be by yourself to
always at least have somebody by your
side
and sometimes it's hard to have somebody
by your side because you can't trust
anybody you know and and
people demonstrate that to me every day
that they can't be trusted
so it's like it's hard
it's very hard
you know
you don't know if you're gonna make it
from one day to the next you know and
you don't get sleep because you have to
be constantly watching your back and
your stuff
your stuff gets robbed by people that
have no hustle that are just lazy and
just watch people and see what they what
they can come up on you know
it's it's very very difficult being
addicted to Fentanyl and and not being
accepted by my family
how's this lifestyle get to you
emotionally it's draining
and I want to keep using because of it
you know if someone just said hey
Jennifer come move in with me I would
stop using like that in a heartbeat I
really would you know
but the fact that rehabs are easy to get
into because there's waiting lists
and if your phone gets stolen that's
even harder to get into a rehab you know
there's a lot of there's a lot of uh
obstacles
it's not easy just for somebody to stop
using
how old are you I'm 27. 27 no kids I
have three kids you do yeah where are
they they're with my family they're with
my mom
and that's another reason why I I do
intend to get off the street soon
um
I every chance I that I'm around a
friend that has a phone I'll call a
rehab and I'll try to get to see if I
can get on their waiting list
because I miss my kids very much and
they miss me too and and it's not worth
it's not worth being out here you know
it's not worth getting high to be away
from my kids at all
the father or fathers of your children
they're not involved
no
how many fathers two or three two
[Music]
fentanyl's a hard drug to it's pretty
free from it's very hard and a lot of
people judge us you know they judge us
and they all think we're pieces of [ __ ]
but really at the end of the day a lot
of people don't know what we go through
on a day-to-day basis and if they knew
if they went through what we go through
I think this world would be less
judgmental
and there'd be a lot more help instead
of people pointing and pointing their
phones at us and and looking down on us
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
um
I wouldn't have
put myself in situations to where
I could have got hurt
you know I wouldn't have went online or
I wouldn't have if I knew the dangers
more I wouldn't have
done certain things that had led me to
this point now
but I thought I was invincible you know
I thought I was invincible like and
clearly I'm not
you know because next time I can end up
dead
and it's not it's not a it's not it's
not it's not it's not a joke you know
it's
not
is this your lowest point right now I
would say yes
it is
because I'm I'm not with my kids
and I'm still using
dear friends
um I have acquaintances
you know I wouldn't call them friends
though
where do you stay at night
I stay at MacArthur Park
you just find a place to crash or do you
have a tent
um I find I'll I'll fall asleep in a
parking lot I'll just not off or I'll
fall asleep at a bus stop I'll fall
asleep wherever I'm at you know if I'm
that exhausted and I'll just fall asleep
what do you do for money uh I boost
I hate doing it I I hate going into the
store you know instant having to still
you know because of the way that people
look at me and stare at me it makes me
feel like a piece of [ __ ]
but they don't know what the hell we
have to go through you know
sometimes I go in there just to steal
food because I'm not hungry you know and
especially when I get caught and they
take the food away from me that feeling
right there
hurts a lot you know
it's very frustrating
especially at the fact that these
employees are just mistreating us you
know like
I know it's not right to steal and stuff
but
what is there there's no other option
you know
how do you think your time on the
streets has changed you
um
I feel like it's it's changed me into a
better person
because like
I I used to be somewhat of a judgmental
person and I'm not anymore like
like I I look at people a lot different
a lot differently now you know and I
accept people a lot more easier and
better now and and I help people you
know even if if even if it's not with a
dollar or with drugs like I'll help them
if I have an extra shirt in my backpack
or or an extra water in my backpack you
know
it's made me a better person
yeah
Jennifer what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
um
the poor I say the most important lesson
in my life I learned is to never stray
away from your kids
it's not worth it no drink no hit no guy
is worth your kids
you know
because I miss him a lot
Jennifer thank you so much for sharing
your story thank you I hope you get back
with your kids thank you for having me
thank you